today's topic i got a little something
can i say
let's go yo what is this come on open
that [ __ ] you open no no you open it
this one's yours i had this you already
opened it no no no i just prepped it
she's already done up look at the tape
no no look at the tape already undid
this [ __ ] just like open it like
you didn't done over here
hold on you gonna be like yeah open it
it's your first time [ __ ] you don't
open it
because i didn't want you to fiddle
around with the scotch tape the whole
time i don't mean to i got keys and a
knife in my pocket i was just trying to
make it easy for you it's like a cake
you know i mean you want a cake on a
locking key you want a cake to just bam
see i didn't touch anything because you
can't say susan
would just keep that's not her name
walnuki won't it that's not her name all
right
tell me that's not a name yo yo listen
listen hey one million one channel and
one more thing one million subscribers
oh that's the best bars you did it one
mission
one channel and one more thing one
million subscribers
congratulations you played yourself
yo you may have started with just a few
viewers true a lot of people don't know
this but we were like sitting around 20
to 30 000 for like
years three years you know what i mean i
specifically been at this since 2013 but
you didn't know how to do it properly
and you didn't have the right tools
that's
not true and the right tools that's not
true that's not true
it's crazy yeah my first two videos went
viral now what you popped it mama
first of all cuz you you knew when you
came to the dramatic [ __ ]
yeah you had that that's what dramatic
that's dramatic
dramatic ass look at the camera tell us
dramatic ass [ __ ]
sitting in the corner yo [ __ ] was fire
the hell you want me to do
yeah you know what i mean the thing was
fine people want to know how did you
meet and that's exactly that
he was actually filming you have to put
some of these reels because the reels
were dope he was doing reels for all the
the battles that i was hosting he was
filming the recaps and stuff like that
so you did a couple of them that was
cool and then i wanted to you
asked me to join for a project and i was
like yeah and i saw how you worked and i
was like
yeah i could pay this yeah the hydrazine
video was actually the first time i
invited him to feature on a video
yeah and then after we were just sitting
down like you want to film some other
stuff no i was i know when i said that
did you hey i said that to you i said
like i want to film some
some stuff i pay you you edit i pay you
to edit i pay you to film
and i said no to that offer yeah you
said no because i want to do that too
because i said you can pay for the dance
stuff which you did
but when it came to like the youtube
stuff i'm like let's just do
collaborations because
exactly let's just do collaboration and
i was like that sounds right okay word
i'm with it let's jump in it so when we
say that we're not friends we weren't i
didn't even notice dude
yeah yeah i know he way was from and i
didn't even know he was in the city
for a minute i'm low-key i know you know
no i'm located no i thought you was just
coming in for the for the advancing
stuff
yeah you've been in the city for a
minute and i was like yeah cool let's do
it i could pay you i'm a private person
like that i don't like to announce that
yeah i'm at it you live your life god
damn it but yeah and now we're here and
yeah we really just kind of blew up
during this pandemic oddly enough it was
really 2020 where
we went from you know 150 000 to a
million
uh in the span of like a very short
period it was kind of crazy
uh just one for now and so you get this
one and then when another one comes out
i'll have all right well yeah i got the
silver one so
and i wasn't going to pay extra for the
silver one because we were still broke
when we had that
oh we were oh this one cost money too oh
yeah yeah it costs a couple of bills
really for a plaque [ __ ] pull that
plaque out i pulled it no no
pull the plaque out like this no no pull
it out bro no please pull it out
at least you said please i got manners
you you said please like james brown
no no no please please down go yes
hold this [ __ ] up this is huge this is
huge this is a big [ __ ]
this is a big [ __ ] look compare this to
this one maybe
yeah this is a big [ __ ] yes exactly
this is a big [ __ ] this is how like
uh you know you know what they got a
white and a black dude an inter like
interracial gang bang and they compare
like
sizes this is what it looks like you
feel me look what it is look
what do you mean are you saying that the
porno stars are living their life like
they're golden look at their life like
the golden
i doubt they know jill scott like that
but uh let's read for you guys the
letter you know what i mean real quick
you may have started with just a few
viewers but your incredible voice
passion and creativity has touched
the lives of so many people around the
world and the community that you've
built is immeasurably enriched
by the stories that you've shared as you
bring people together damn you heard
that
ladies we're bringing you also together
with us right we don't hate y'all it's
really you to hate
us to honor your incredible milestone we
are proud to present you with the gold
creator award we hope that this special
recognition will inspire you and remind
you how much you mean to so many but not
demonetize us in like a week or two
it's a great privilege to have you part
of the journey blah blah blah your
sincerely
souls and susan got bars yeah big thank
you you guys you guys were a huge part
of this uh
process it's kind of crazy that it
happened during the period it did but um
you know we're we're grateful and
you guys supporting us the coolest thing
about you guys supporting us it means i
get to support the people around me
and that's kind of the thing that i like
the most so for me it's um
just grateful i'm not surprised because
remember when i told you like even when
we were starting i'm like
i think we got that like a lot of people
would enjoy i think they just haven't
discovered it
yeah you said that you said that a
couple of times yeah and i was like my
own self
you know what yeah sure
but you know here we are and uh it's
interesting what's interesting it's like
it's interesting to
to to go from being the one who reacts
to being reacted to
yes you know that transition has been a
little bit different
um yes but just just for the record yeah
uh i don't watch all these roles that
you
get react to us i'm just kidding all
right that's fair maybe you don't you
know and
it's interesting to see like the
progression of like how much the content
we do tries to mean to some people so
you know in that sense i'm really
grateful to be able to
do this for you guys uh and that that
just being able to help folks if it does
help at all
that i'm happy to do so that's my
thoughts on reaching one million
uh it's really cool and i'm grateful and
you know even if we lose it tomorrow
then it is what it is i'm glad that we
got to do this much
let's get to two now in six months yeah
two million in six months i don't know i
don't put timelines on anything
we it's so unpredictable yeah i learned
not to get attached to outcomes like you
know when we had fifty thousand i was
doing the same type of content
we had a million i'm doing the same type
of stuff you know i'm not trying to be
like
i need to get here and need to get there
and i think part of the reason why we're
able to get here even when times were
like
not very fruitful was because of the
fact that we didn't stress it
no and we feel what's in the in this
dusty ass room
yeah i mean i don't feel like i've
changed
i don't think i've changed either you
know my [ __ ] have known me since i was
like 20
they're like well people don't realize
like who abba is on screen
is how whoever is off screen yeah but
that's what most people say to us when
they meet us whenever we do shows
like oh my god you're the same guys what
did you got a nap yeah yeah this is not
an
act this is not like okay we're going to
prep up because that's not me let me get
my preach voice
hey [ __ ] no it's not it's not
it's not it's
not that it's not it ain't it it's just
us and i think that's part of the reason
why you guys like coming here but it's
also you know
part of the reason why we [ __ ] up at
times you know we do this in one shot
no retakes no reshoots and we just go at
it so
um i think being authentic and just
chilling has kind of been our
our go-to and it's worked out well so
thanks for chilling with us
yeah yeah oh just by the way happy
[ __ ] are not even subscribed so
let's become like a meme you know that
yeah the meme is like like pretty much
every youtuber says that now because
it's part
but that's that's pretty much the trend
yeah a bunch of y'all just treating us
like you know we're tender hookups like
you can just get to
get the goods without committing and uh
we'd like you to take the leap all right
that's been cool we'll just see where it
goes from here can't wait for the best
this [ __ ] to open back up
what [ __ ] don't you wanna do live shows
you wanna go on tour and [ __ ] uh i wanna
go i wanna go see the world yeah
these [ __ ] don't believe we do
stand up and i understand because they
ain't seen it
they ain't seen it yeah it's really
weird that's weird yeah but some of them
are religious
[Music]
[Laughter]
i just you know don't believe in god but
you can't believe we do stand up yeah
dude i mean if you haven't seen it
there's no point of us putting
our show abba does it sometimes put his
shows out there
but even then it's not your material
it's like crowded
stuff like little things but yeah we're
also young in the game you know what i
mean like four or five years a lot of
people that you've seen before
super green have like 12 to 15 years and
so it's a different ball game yeah we'd
like to go on tour and do our thing you
know do a mixture of like stand up and
then also just
chatting with the crowd folks i'm going
out there just to learn that's the thing
yeah people expect that it's going to be
like a show where it is
nah i'm learning yeah i'm still green at
this and
like i can't even say that i've been
doing this for five years
cause there is a year that we haven't
done [ __ ]
i know i know what are you looking
forward to doing the most in the near
future
i just want to do those [ __ ] yeah that's
that's i think that's been the standard
hasn't it yeah i mean that's that's been
my idea but like
maybe you got different like goals in
that regards because people don't know
you have your own career aside from this
you do too i mean this is mostly most of
this you know but you're out there doing
acting stuff because
the thing is the thing is the thing is
my brain gets bored
and to keep doing what i do i need to
diversify
what i do yeah or else i'm going to be
like uh and like
at some point i'm not efficient in what
i do
yeah because i can't just do one thing
yeah [ __ ]
ask me so if you had to choose well
that's the point i don't have to that's
why i'm doing this
cuz i don't have to choose but yeah i'm
doing my thing doing my acting thing
yeah i want to i want to act of course
but this thing is still a thing
and people know that this is the thing i
go to audition
they know there's a thing they notice
they know this
they notice man they know this is a
thing so
you know what's been so interesting also
about this transition it's like people
like
oh my god are rich people problems and
i'm like [ __ ] like less than a year ago
i was like
near the poverty you know what i'm
saying
like i wasn't even making enough to be
taxed listen you know so it's just
interesting
that you just hit a point people just
think like now you're in a different
like mine it's not really yeah
here's the thing i got money you got cat
you got okay you ain't got
giraffe money i don't have giraffe money
but i don't need to get the draft money
my whole point is like it's not because
you hand someone
a bunch of cash that everything all
automatically change of course you know
certain aspects of my life are
definitely slightly different and
important ones
but it's just the mental it's hard to
you don't think in that mindset does
that make sense well i think every day
like i'm still poor
i'm gonna break it out like this yeah
you see all these rappers that get a lot
of money
but get cut on dumb charges like having
a gun
yeah you have security yeah why you're
getting cut
for you know what i mean but it's still
the same mindset the same street mindset
that you have that
oh people now oh yeah you're gonna get
at me instead of letting the security
deal with it you deal with it it's still
the same mindset yeah so you could throw
a whole bunch of money to someone
the mindset the mindset's not
necessarily gonna be different
yeah i agree with it like i said
personally i said that before i'ma say
it again
personally i'm happy this is happening
now yeah i agree
i don't think i would have been able to
handle it well uh a long time ago so
yeah anyways you guys been part of this
so it's a big thank you to you guys and
uh that's it we'll just keep making
content you guys keep enjoying if you
guys want to support more ways we do
have the patreon where we have exclusive
content
so if you want to see other adword
preach bonus footages from some of your
favorite videos as well as archived
stuff from like way back that nobody
else has access to
uh jump on the patreon otherwise we
still offer you guys five to six free
videos a week so
i don't think anybody can complain no i
can't so
you could yeah keep enjoying cheers
foreign